prime minister sugar
yoshihide thank you for hosting this
important summit
to accelerate safe and effective
vaccination
everywhere we all need to step up
efforts
therefore i appreciate that leaders at
the g20 global health summit in may
committed to working closely together
this is the only way
to get out of the current crisis and
to prevent a new pandemic
kovacs plays a central role in this
europe is investing in kovacs both
financially
and by sharing vaccines because we
believe this is the best way to ensure
universal fair and affordable access
to covered 19 vaccines our common goal
is to leave no one behind that we
promised more than one year ago
when we launched covax and this is still
true today
team europe has been a lead supporter of
kovac since
the start more than one third of kovacs
funding comes from team europe
the european union has mobilized 2.8
billion euros so far
i'm glad that others have joined our
efforts
kovacs has delivered over 71 million
doses in 125 countries to date
including to countries like afghanistan
or yemen
where there is little chance of vaccines
arriving
without coverts this shows
the strength of multilateralism and
collective solutions
but there is still a lot of work to be
done
today wealthier countries are
vaccinating much faster than others
but the world will not overcome the
pandemic if these differences stay
no one will be safe until everyone is
safe
team europe has just committed to donate
at least
100 million doses to low and
middle-income countries by the end of
the year
most of these will be delivered through
covax
the eu vaccine strategy is delivering
not only for europeans
but also for the rest of the world i
trust
more will come as soon as deliveries
pick up
i'm particularly grateful that the eu's
industrial partners have committed
themselves to
they will make available 1.3 billion
doses in 2021 biontech
pfizer johnson johnson and moderna
will provide these vaccines at no profit
for the low-income countries and at
lower prices
for the middle-income countries and they
will supply an additional 1 billion
or more doses in 2022
it's in our mutual interest to end this
global pandemic
as soon as possible
and that is why the european union
together with the european investment
bank
will reorient 300 million euro to kovacs
this is team europe's contribution to
avat
kovac's cost-sharing rapid finance
scheme
this scheme will help vaccine purchases
in africa
and it will foster links between kovacs
and the african union
you can continue to count on team
europe's commitment
we are here for the long haul we are
here until we end the pandemic
everywhere thank you very much